we want you to tell us about the day
after you died hey youtubers its charlie
this week on agents of shield is the
mid-season finale J August Richards
comes back as a super-powered Mike but
it turns out the agent coulson is the
one that centipede really wants to talk
to we also got some nice callbacks to
the Avengers as well as a teaser for
possible superhero cameo in a coming
episode so let's do our top 5 moments
then I'll do my review remember agents
of shield is gonna be off the air for
about 4 weeks so I'm gonna be doing
bonus videos be sure to subscribe to get
them all so here we go top five moments
number 5 the clairvoyant this person
could either be someone using alien tech
or could be someone actually from the
Marvel Universe there's actually a
person in the Marvel Universe named
clairvoyant she was the original black
widow
there's also Madame web as well as
Agatha Harkness it's hard to know what
the secret is really going to be behind
this clairvoyant person but I assume
that it's going to be something they're
not gonna reveal till the season finale
I feel like that secret is actually
almost more closely guarded than the
secret behind Coulson's survival number
four did I be Captain America's time
Iago says this really funny entrance
where he's basically pushing a bulldozer
down a football field
turns out Captain America is just a
little bit faster they actually paid the
joke off even more later in the episode
when he said that his son thought that
he was working construction the big
takeaway from that though is how fast
can Captain America push a bulldozer
down a football field I would be willing
to bet that that stat is on the back of
his trading card number three main war
battle it out so this is obviously a
clear metaphor for sex but doesn't that
not make you wonder what their actual
sexual escapades look like if they're
that intense outside of a hotel room
then what does actual sex for them look
like I mean is it like an MMA
championship fight no judging raise your
hand if you had paid to see that fight
number two the cellist a big callback to
the Avengers we don't know a lot about
Coulson's secret girlfriend but we do
find out that he's been peeping on her
since he's been dead or assumed to been
dead
I laughed pretty hard when Coulson
totally threw a red flag onwards comment
about May obviously Coulson didn't catch
that hidden reference that warded
implied but clearly he is asking for
trouble
and my number one moment the day after
Coulson died I was so surprised when it
turned out centipede really wanted
Coulson obviously they want to find out
what the secret of his survival was so
they can basically find a cure for death
if you didn't catch it during the
episode they were trying to imply that
all of the centipede soldiers are
basically just burning through their
life force that much faster they have to
eat more they have to sleep more and
they break down faster given the shield
is only about half way through its
season it has a full 22 episodes I
didn't think that they would be paying
off this Coulson story until the end of
the season they did say they would be
teasing it out but kudos to them for
giving it to us early I have to wonder
though if they were basically throwing
us this bone because so many people were
complaining about the show not being
integrated enough with the Marvel
Universe let me know what your favorite
moment was from the episode though and
remember shield isn't back for about
four weeks I'll be doing lots of bonus
episodes though be sure to subscribe to
get them a couple of interesting things
about the rest of the season though so
in the teaser for episode 11 the next
episode it actually says that we're
going to learn the secret of Coulson
survival I think that's a bit of a
misdirection I think we'll learn a
little bit about it but I don't think
it'll be totally explained but Clark
Gregg in real life was actually teasing
on Twitter that stingray might be
visiting the series as part of the
Pegasus project storyline that was
teased in the pilot he's actually a
minor character from the Marvel Universe
but it is interesting to know that
they're trying to bring more superheroes
overall I thought the episode was a
great mid-season finale it really up the
action with J August Richards and some
superhero with centipede soldiers it
invoked the big bad centipede as well as
the clairvoyant and it gave us a very
clear timeline on one of our biggest
questions we've had so far
how did Coulson survive after the
Avengers the characters are really
starting to come together too so the may
and ward subplot now has made them a lot
more interesting they're sexy times
subplot previously they kind of felt
like statues so I feel like things like
this really give the characters some
extra places to go that being said I do
feel like Fitz and Simmons really need
some sort of subplot some sort of secret
if you're on a TV show based on
something as expansive as the Marvel
Universe and you don't have a secret
that you want the other characters to
not find out then you just are not quite
as interesting as everyone else so it's
just not as much fun to watch let me
know in the comments below what do you
want Fitz and Simmons secrets to be they
don't have to be the same secret and
obviously they can't be boning because
it's kind of like May and Ward's thing
and what about you guys do you have any
secrets that you want to tell me don't
worry I won't tell anyone I'm really
good to keep it secrets I promise in
other news The Hobbit is this week I
will be posting my review either
Wednesday or a Thursday night late it
depends on when I get to see the movie
be sure and go see it it's going to be
amazing it has 100 percent more Benedict
Cumberbatch in it right now click here
to get last week's episode
shield and click here to get my top 10
predictions for the rest of Walking Dead
next year thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you